when you talk about the process of this
song did he come to you quickly
yeah yeah i mean the the first half of
our album
fell together within a few weeks and we
recorded
the first half in about two days we
thought we were just demoing these tunes
right no one knew who we were isn't that
great though
to have the casual approach hey this is
just like a demo
yeah exactly because they don't then you
don't stress about it
a lot of it's one take you know was
figure it out one take
yeah yeah ben's ben's the first drum
take
is the take while they're on the record
i think the third vocal take
which is why you know it's so awful so
do both of you
show up with a tune at different times
yeah so take me through the process of
let's say figure it out so
where does this occur um so
figure it out would have would have
started with the intro riff and then
you had that intro riff in your head
that was floating around yeah yeah i
think i was messing around with it
yeah just with that and someone had just
taught me how to hammer on and hammer
off
with what i'm stressed with that
hammering thing you're doing you know
you seem to be pulling on the strings
you're just hammering away on the on the
on the top part of your
bit of a show off you see however any
opportunity to point one hand in the air
i'm gonna
i'm gonna grab the ball by the horns you
guys look at each other a lot while when
you uh
when you play yeah you need those visual
cues right
absolutely i have to i have to see some
of the stuff
it's like a marriage it is and so when
you have a little idea you bring it then
you bring it in a studio and then you
start to jam together
that's right yeah every every song has
started with
what feels like a small weak feeble idea
sometimes on an acoustic as well and
then we bring it to this and
see you see what it's made right here's
a song called figure it out you boys
did this by you had a little idea you
thought you were making a demo tape
you made this and it turned into a hit
song here we go you ready can you handle
this
we're ready all right go ahead boys
nothing better to do when i'm stuck on
you i'm still while i'm here trying to
figure it out
i'm getting hard to sleep but this is my
dreams love is killing me
trying to figure it out
nothing better to do when i'm stuck on
you i'm still while i'm here trying to
figure it out
[Music]
so
[Music]
fell on you but you didn't know i
planned it out
[Music]
nothing better to do when i'm stuck on
you i'm still
on
[Music]
i'm still trying to here it out
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
holy mackerel that is something fun to
watch
that is crazy
you